all right it's time for us to see some
animals not this guy this is animals
other animals maybe start to get he
stroll or something oh no yeah oh my God
I'm asking you questions did you even
hear me
good morning
my new hat that I got yesterday this is
my new backpack nice nice uh today is
Epcot nope ah today is Animal Kingdom
that's it we're gonna see the animals
hey everyone excited thanks there's no
banks no thanks I'm excited to go see
animals let's go
[Music]
finally we can get our coffee
first time during our trip
morning coffee that's funny coffee
[Music]
all right it's time for us to see some
animals not this guy this is other
animals
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we finished the Safari ride I got a
little bit headachy because the road was
very bumpy very nice yeah yeah very
Buffy and I got headache and I think
it's also because the heat too
start to maybe start to get history or
something oh no yeah anyways okay off to
the next one next one we'll go inside
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it was fun
that it smelled I didn't smell anything
oh my God I'm asking you questions did
you even hear me did you like the ride I
did but mine was broken I didn't get any
smell I didn't get any rain on me did
you get movement I got movement it was
fun though as well I smelled did you
know I smelled it I had nothing I got no
smell
yeah it got sprayed though nothing yeah
anyways it was great it was good this
this thread is really well done next up
we're gonna grab some lunch because
kids are hungry
[Music]
all right we finished lunch River
Journey time how was your lunch Evan I
liked it you like it I didn't really
like mine my noodle was very kind of
sour but tofu was good I'm not a
complainer you know well I'm not
complaining I'm just saying
saying how I feel what's on my what was
on my taste buds so anyways I even enjoy
his lunch Catherine enjoyed her lunch
because they got rice I got noodle the
noodle wasn't that good anyway movina to
the river ride
foreign
[Music]
thank you
that was a nice relaxing River Avatar
ride oven
yeah relaxing I almost fell asleep oh
wow no no it was it was too too pretty
to fall asleep too actually they did a
good job yeah but you did a good job
yeah yeah good good good I like it next
up we're going to The Lion King show
we're gonna watch it she's gonna have
fun we're gonna have fun let's go
[Music]
next stop we're gonna get a snack or
drink because if you see my my
um my neck I'm sweating
very
moist
salty salty oh man my my neck this area
let's go let's go get some drinks
all right everyone got their specialty
drinks
time to chill relaxing chill Jeffrey has
like caramel ribbon crunch too
[Music]
Uncle Evan seen as Evan and I
know Catherine has a strawberry yummy
Hayden has the matcha chocolate double
chocolate
chip
yum
[Music]
all right we finished a drink everyone
had a good relaxing time refreshing now
we're gonna head up to two different
spots Evan and Hayden and Catherine are
going to the water ride
Jeffrey and I go into the roller coaster
okay off we go Jeffrey you and I game on
all right this is it the Mount Everest
ride
[Music]
[Music]
that's nice Hayden got all wet soaked
soaked tayden got soaked yes
they tell you in line everybody will get
wet and some of you will get soaked
that's it for the day full day gonna go
home shower shower chill eat yeah yeah
and then yeah yeah let's go home
we came back I make some dinner with um
basically pasta with white sauce it's
good I got a plan for tomorrow finally
for tomorrow Evan is planning for
tomorrow
kids at the dinner good is the dinner
good too good too good yeah
okay good enjoy guys today we are going
to
Epcot baby and if you want to see what
happens there click the video right
there next to us continue to believe
we'll see you there